do you think it would be possible if you
were an intellectual
uh like you are at the beginning of the
20th century would you be able to
predict the rest of the 20th century no
I I don't think at all I think there
were so many
um
out of nowhere turns that no one would
have seen their them coming for and as
an example
um Lenin seizing power and making the
Bolshevik Revolution a reality was
regarded as utopian and insane uh the
fact that he pulled it off is close to
miraculous and it was quite literally
unprecedented
um the fact that so that's a very big
one which aspect of it sorry to
interrupt which aspect was hard to
predict that a singular figure with just
some ideas would be able to take so much
power and and maintain that power and
remake that Society so drastically so
quickly despite such opposition also not
just a set of temporary protests by
Hooligans that lead to
um turmoil in the short term but then
stabilizes but literally changes the
entirety of the society yeah ludendorff
who was the German general he's like all
right we got to get this the Russians
out of world war one he's the one who's
like all right let's get this lunatic
Lenin who already tried and failed to
have a Revolution in Russia let's send
them back there and he's just gonna
cause problems to everybody and it's
going to be great because it's gonna
weaken Russia and then our Eastern Front
isn't going to have to be a problem and
then to his surprise and everyone else
is including you know anarchists and
Communists worldwide uh they pulled off
this you know October Revolution and
then for a while it's like all right I
mean I mean I think my understanding is
even people at the time in St Petersburg
and in Moscow were like what does this
even mean right like no one took it
seriously and then very quickly you had
the checkout and and the secret police
and all these other kind of
implementations of the you know the
communist state and people like oh
they're not messing around but they're
like all right this is this is not going
to last for for long and you know the
USA the US and day we didn't even
recognize the Soviet Union's legitimacy
for a very long time there were no
diplomatic relations after a certain
point it's like who's if you don't
recognize Lenin and Stalin's government
who's the government of this of Russia
or the Soviet Union is it the Czar like
you have to recognize that it's just
they're not going anywhere so that was
something that was not I think very
predictable the Great Depression in
retrospect there were certain things
that were predictable but it was not at
all the case that it needed to last as
long as it did in the states as FDR made
it do so there's all sorts of things I
mean if they uh
um
fought Germany's re-militarization you
know World War World War II could have
been prevented if you didn't have the
Treaty of Versailles would you have the
hyperinflation would you have Hitler
these are all I think Choose Your Own
Adventure moments where things could
have gone in other directions I don't I
don't believe this kind of idea this is
a very Marxist idea that like history is
inevitable and once you start with
certain premises the contradictions kind
of unfold I I think that's ridiculous